o povo só hoje foi mais para fazer
estarão aqui o contrato ultimar o
negócio em si nem fazer este par do
elástico foi só aqui
ou seja é uma chance a mais o seu pv num
campo de batalha feroz brasil só então
vamos lá começar a especular projeto só
pra você precisa estar no pac 2
elásticos vão precisar de materiais como
molas exceção de plástico uma loja de
madeira mas que ainda precisa de três
quintos do hospital da frança que mais
vão perder uma bola e elásticos ainda
esquecendo claro cola uma coleta rápida
que você pode usar outra qualquer e pra
começar vamos aqui jantar com os três
coletivos por aqui três pontos escola
três motores e fazer o mesmo por outro
lado quando os caras só por mais cola da
prestação para forçar a escultura
agora vamos colocar uma bola numa das
extremidades
quisemos também da campanha as contas já
criadas agora com elástico frouxo ser
aqui ou forçá la a abortar a volta assim
e claro da extremidade máquina é cima da
bola é agora vamos fazer aqui uma peça
feita para conseguir furos e latim
você concorda assim aquela partida e
agora é só colar
agora vou fazer a crônica
primeiro claro que uma peça assim para
aumentar o tamanho da arma
agora com os outros móveis que são um
bocado maior fazer isso em caixa sem
muito simples mas não parece mesmo uma
arma dentro da área só para enfeitar ele
já está bem só porque só mostrar como
carga estava da maneira mais rápida e
vocês querem me ajudar pois carrega numa
ótima e agora é só puxar o laço baixa
hoje em cima deles tira é só comprar
produtos que tenham estado sobre o
joinha e até o próximo verão